[Music]
local Andrea hi everyone thanks for the
invite
so I'm primarily a roboticist and I
spent a lot of my time worrying about
robot objective functions on how to
create robot objective functions so a
very brief one-minute guided journey is
that back towards all the way the
beginning of my PhD I was working on
trajectory optimization so this is a
problem when you're trying to find a
trajectory from a start to a goal that
avoids obstacles and you would like some
planner that smoothly bends the
trajectory out of collisions and so you
have two things that you care about you
care about staying as far away from
obstacles as you can and you care about
being as smooth and as efficient as you
can then those two are at odds with each
other and so you have to figure out how
to trade-off between them and of course
you can think about hard constraints and
so on but you know that was that was one
of the things that was the main kind of
bottleneck of this whole thing and then
things got even worse from there because
I then moved into a world where what is
the right kind of objective function
wasn't something objective with
something dictated by by the end user
and so we were working on a shared
autonomy kind of project where the robot
was trying to infer that what a person
was the operator wanted to do and then
try to figure out how to assist the
person and there the robot had its own
trade-off to make between doing what the
person literally said to do and doing
what the person what it thought the
person wants it to do and again
different people wanted different things
there and you know then I moved on to
making robots move in a more intent
expressive way
and so again there we cared about intent
expression as a feature of the motion
but we also cared about things like
efficiency as a feature of the motion
and again ran into trade-offs and so you
can kind of see this story going up
recently at Berkeley I got more and more
involved with autonomous driving and
there is not just two or three things
that you care about you care about many
many different things and it becomes
sort of a mess to try to figure out how
to trade-off between them and so on and
so forth so this is all not surprising
because I remember back back in the day
when I wrote the Russell and Norvig AI
book they had this beautiful example of
how hard it is to write down objective
functions for robots in the example that
they gave was that of a robot vacuum
cleaner they said look imagine you have
a robot vacuum cleaner a fairly
reasonable objective function you might
write down is to give it a reward for
sucking in dust right the more dust gets
like stuff the better it is and so then
they showed that the optimal policy for
this is one word the robot sucks in some
dust but then instead of going off and
collecting other does from other places
in your house it just dumps the dust and
then sucks it again right it just goes
in this list that's an example of kind
of that's not why we want the robot to
do but it's the behavior that emerges
out of something that the first glance
seems like a very reasonable objective
function to write them and so inspired
by kind of these struggles of trying to
formulate objective functions trying to
write down objective functions for
robots we spend in my lab the last year
or so thinking about this problem of how
do I learn how do I come up with these
these things that are in people's heads
implicitly but they can't explicitly
right now
at least not very easily it seems no
what's a way for robots to do that and I
just want to point out that we're
thinking about this for two very
important reasons one is to be able to
make the robot like we were saying
acting the way that the person actually
wants it to act and then the second
reason is that we want this role
to interact with people so learning
objective functions that people have
kind of in their head implicitly
is also a good way to start figuring out
how people are going to behave in new
situations so that you're able to
interact with them so the kind of ground
this is an example it's a bit like
saying we want to be able to learn
objective functions both so that we can
enable for instance a car to drive
according to the passenger preferences
that's one reason to try to learn the
objective function that a person has in
their head for how they want the robot
to act but it's also interesting to
think about learning objective functions
that people might implicitly have in
their head to be able to actually
predict how people will drive right so
if I want to interact on the road with
people with human driven vehicles then
we might want to discover sort of or
learn what what objective function
drives their behavior so that we can
actually predict what they're gonna do
and in new situations we're with them on
the road now of course there's a an
established way of doing this and it's
called inverse reinforcement learning so
I think most of you know about inverse
reinforcement learning the idea is that
you have a person and the person
implicitly knows some parameters the
parameters of the objective function
that we're gonna call theta and but
again can't explicate them can't write
them down but just but what they can't
do is they can act approximately
optimally according to them so so the
person can demonstrate behavior where
the probability of the person taking one
particular trajectory for instance is
higher when the behavior is less costly
with respect to their underlying utility
function so I mean this is just one way
of formulating that it comes from the
principle of maximum entropy and so
that's the kind of core assumption
University enforcement learning you've
got to have an expert that can write
down this data but they can act
approximately optimally according to it
I'm going to have a robot observer who
gets to see the person's actions and
know that the person's actions can be
literally the person act
or they could be the person actually
operating the robot and telling the
robot what to do
I'm sure you're gonna see some talks on
Wednesday on that sort of interface as
well but regardless the the robot from
the autonomy side is sort of sitting
there observing these these controls
these actions from the person and it's
trying to figure out what theta is
underlying these actions right so one
way to think about this is they're
trying to find the theta that explains
the data that you've seen knowing the
maximum likelihood estimation or more
generally you can think of the robot
taking these these demonstrations these
actions for the person as evidence about
the person the underlying theta and
running a Bayesian belief update on the
safe space of parameters so that's
enforced reinforcement learning in a
nutshell it's been very very successful
because it can represent behavior in
this very very compact way in the form
of a reward function that's kind of
underlying that behavior that's pretty
cool and we've been using it a lot in
our driving work but sort of the more we
thought about inverse reinforcement
learning the more we realized that it is
implicitly making two assumptions that
we might not necessarily want to be
making so the first assumption that
inverse reinforcement learning is
implicitly making is that our robot here
at least during the learning phase is a
passive observer the robot sort of sits
there observes the behavior and then
goes off and and learns and then acts
according to the learner behavior and
you know robots are robots because
they're actuated they're actual agents
who can take physical actions in the
world and so it might be useful to start
thinking about leveraging this in order
to improve learning and I found I think
I'm preaching to the choir here but I
found the glorious video on the Internet
to exemplify this so the idea is sort of
that you can if you all you could do is
actually observe this turtle right and
you try to figure out what kind of
turtle it is you might go throughout
your life thinking that it's a very nice
gentle little turtle even though maybe
it looks a little weird but you know
regular turtle and then but if you
actually get to take physical actions
that probe at the turtle then you might
quickly realize that it's this you know
raging destruction I don't know what
kind of turtle s sort of suggest that
passively observing the world is okay
but but to really get information in
some cases it might be actually useful
to act right to take action so we might
say that inverse reinforcement learning
is great but maybe one desiderata is
that if we have robots who can act we
should be able to leverage these actions
to improve learn so that's the first
assumption that robots are passive
observers that we might want to change
the second assumption is a little is a
little weird but essentially when we're
doing the inverse reinforcement learning
we're implicitly asking people to behave
like uninterested experts and here's
what I mean by that so we're asking
people to behave optimally according to
their theta and that's a little bit like
trying to learn gymnastics by watching
Gabby Douglas so or or when I learned
how to drive I learned how to drive from
my significant other he drives like a
maniac watching him drive in his
expertly way wasn't exactly that useful
for me right and the kink and I think
I'm preaching to the choir what's useful
for me it's good because I had the skill
level that looks something like this
right so so I was not ready to observe
the way he drives and make anything out
of it he kind of had to dumb it down for
me and bring it down to my level and
similarly we know we don't learn
gymnastics from gap by watching Gabby
Douglas perform we learned gymnastics by
getting coaches who kind of break down
the tasks emphasize certain things right
they coach they don't they are not just
uninterested experts so perhaps a second
desiderata is that we should be asking
people to act in their expertly ways we
should be asking people to explicitly
try to teach these robots and robots
should actually embrace that and sort of
take advantage of that and so those are
the two things that we found and then we
started thinking of okay well university
enforcement learning does
satisfy these is there a problem
formulation that that might wear if you
solve that problem these sort of things
just emerge out of the optimal solution
and so what we did is we ended up
formulating learning as a cooperative
two-player game and so the idea is that
you make it a game so that you have two
agents and they both take actions you
don't have a someone who is acting and
someone who is observing and you make it
cooperative so that you actually give
the person and an interest into the
robots learning so when we go back to
inverse reinforcement
all right let me try to fix that
hopefully that would be ok alright so
when we go back to university first by
learning what we decided to do is you
know first step is now you have two
agents and they can both take actions in
the physical world
you could formulate it in such a way
that these actions are not independent
of each other they're coupled and
they're coupled through the objective
functions that these two agents have so
the person has their objective functions
but importantly how much payoff the
person gets depends on what the robot
decides to do as well and the robot
might have its own objective function so
so that's nice because now you have a
robot that in order to to figure out
what to do it should have information
about the about data and then you can go
a step further and make this cooperative
and say well actually both agents are
gonna get payoffs according to the same
utility function so now it's an actual
cooperative game that they're playing
together and so the when you well if you
were to solve this what you would get is
a tuple of policies one for the human
and one for the robot that have these
nice properties where the robot would
actually act to try to improve its
estimation because the nor for the robot
to do well and used to know what data is
and not only that but the person will
try to help the robot get a good
estimation because the person gets
better payoff if the robot actually
knows what it's doing and so so that was
really nice you know we thought of this
we said yay success but then of course
there's there's the challenge of
tractability to consider which is how on
earth will we actually solve this this
type of game and inversely enforcement
learning is really one approximation
that you can make to be able to solve
this tractable e and the approximation
is in particular that we're gonna fix
the humans policy to be an expert
demonstration and we're gonna have the
robot computer what in game theoretic
turns would be called the best response
to the humans policy where the robot
basically assumes that there's not going
to be any more information from the
person after they see the person's
rejected
then the robot does the situation belief
update and then proceeds according to
that belief distribution going forward
so that's what we do in enforced
reinforcement learning and but then
sending it up as this game sort of
enables us to think about what are other
approximations that we could make that
maybe take us a little bit closer to
these desert errata that we have about
robots acting and about people yeah
question over there you're doing
responses like it looks like an
uncooperative game and you're looking so
if you were to solve the original
cooperative game you would get a couple
of policies that are a Nash equilibrium
right what we're saying is that that's
okay in cooperative games they're just
their best responses to each other but
their best responses according to the
same utility function and so everyone's
happy and so it's Bert in particular the
equilibrium that has the highest utility
right that's all we're saying is it
called
so this is this so so first I set up a
cooperative game we said here you know
there you can you could potentially
solve this but it's not tractable and
here we're just pointing out that
inverse reinforcement learning is a very
rough way a very rough way of
approximating a solution where you're
very you're basically saying I'm not
gonna actually solve the game I'm gonna
commit to a policy for the person and
the person is gonna act in as an expert
and the robot is gonna assume that it's
not gonna it's gonna just see the the
person act and then stop getting
information and so then do you know the
robot will do the thing that's the best
for it to do and which means estimate
that that theta based on the
demonstration that you have that you've
seen and then act according to that so
that's just what you how inverse
reinforcement learning relates to this
original game right it's not the it's
not the solution to the game in any way
in fact it very explicitly assumes fixed
fixes the person's policy to something
that we'll see in a little bit is not
the optimal thing to do and the game but
now that we can understand inverse
reinforcement learning in the context of
this type of game setup we can think of
what are other kind of approximations
that we could do that are maybe a little
bit better right
again we're not gonna fully solve the
game at least not in continuous state
and actions basis but you know we might
be able to have an approximate solution
that actually gets closer to the
desiderata that we have and so there are
two important parts of that right so
there is actually making it a game
namely the robot is now a player 2 and
gets to act and the second part is the
cooperative part and so so I want to
kind of first we're gonna go into and
I'm gonna share a little bit with you on
the game part and then I'm gonna share a
little bit with you on the cooperative
bar so first when it comes to the game
side and the particular sort of domain
that we're gonna have in mind here is in
particular a domain and autonomous
driving where the reason we want to
estimate this theta that is internal to
the person is because we're assuming
that the person acts occur
to it and we want to be able to use this
as a way to actually interact with
people on the road people to anticipate
what they're gonna do so that we know
what the robot should do and it's
important to be able to do this kind of
as a as an ongoing interaction because
different people drive in very different
ways right so so you see a new driver
maybe at a new time of day they're
probably gonna drive in a slightly
different way than the drivers that
you've seen before in particular they're
people who are more aggressive more
distracted and so on and so forth right
so you can think of them as you can
think of all these drug driving styles
as parameterizing and some having from
this you know some particular theta that
corresponds to this may be the
aggressive driver puts a very low weight
on on safety compared to efficiency
right and so on okay so going back to
this approximation that the inverse
reinforcement learning makes we're gonna
make a slight improvement to this and
and we're gonna make that sorry I just
wanna skip ahead to something
so so this is what there we go this is
why the inverse reinforcement learning
did right and so if you apply university
enforcement learning directly in this
setting um let's say that you're on the
road and you're trying to as you drive
next to this person figure out what kind
of what is their internal theta right is
this person an aggressive driver are
they paying attention or not what is
going on with them so that you know how
to interact with that and so the first
thing that we notice is that if you're
just driving next to them unfortunately
and you're updating your keep on
updating your belief based on the
actions that they keep on taking right
you have an observation model for that
everything's great but you're not
actually getting a lot of information
because for the most part aggressive
versus versus defensive drivers terms
were paying attention drivers were not
paying attention they're kind of driving
in the same way when you're not sort of
messing with that in any way and so so
if the robot just does inverse
reinforcement learning here then it's
not gonna get a lot of information and
what we know this happens in this type
of example for instance is that if the
robot for instance needed to merge left
it would have no choice but to let the
person through first if it doesn't have
enough enough kind of gap in traffic to
merge you in front of them but the
person through and merge behind right so
this is the typical behavior that you
see in autonomous cars today where
they're sort of very defensive they're
waiting for everyone to go and then if
they finally kind of get there creeping
but that's not what we do right so I
Drive on the bay bridge to get here
every day and I Drive home every day
when everyone's trying to get into the
city and every single day I have to do
something like this to actually make my
way home right um have to actually stick
myself in front of people and force them
to have some sort of reaction to what
I'm doing right namely hit the brake and
make a little bit of space for me and if
we don't do things like this then
[Music]
the robots get stuck essentially this is
one of the best articles on the matter
it's an article from back I think it was
a couple of years ago where the Google
self-driving car got stuck at an
intersection because people kept on
inching forward into into the
intersection there was never a big
enough gap to actually go through so the
car was just there and hung out until
the driver finally took over and so so
so this is kind of one sorry what
there's a person at the wheel so so the
way they work is they only intervene
when something is about to happen so so
they didn't intervene for a while well
so so this is what happened and and you
know similarly kind of what going back
to the Bay Bridge situation is the kind
of thing where it's very polite to let
everyone go through but at some point
you know you need to go home and so you
need to sort of insert yourself at some
point in traffic so yeah so basically
what we did here is we thought well what
if we approve this a little bit and
instead of you know just observing the
damage the person's actions and and
computing a bus response to that what if
you know we explicitly allowed with the
robot to act and we explicitly think
about so if we're allowed the robot to
act and all of a sudden what the person
does also depends explicitly on what the
robot decides to do and that changes the
observation model that the robot has and
now we have an opportunity to do
something that I think happens very a
lot in this community which is to
actually actively learn right to
actually gather information so we can
decide on actions to take that
explicitly incentivize information gain
about this disbelief right and it's
explicitly because depending on what the
robot does you'll see the person doing
different things and some things are can
be more informative than others and so
of course we don't actually we can't
compute this directly we have to
actually take an expectation over the
possible our belief over data because we
don't actually know what data is there
for we don't know what observations were
gonna receive
so but this is one way to set up the
problem where again we're not solving
the the full game
we're just saying look the person is
still going to be fixed to a policy to
an expert policy just like it was in
reinforcement learning but now we're
going to just allow the robot to act and
see what the robot can do in order to
actually gather more information about
the person's utility information gain
about the robots belief on theta because
I don't model the expectation is the
same model then H of B and H of the time
are the same so if you take like an
absolute value of a square value I can
see like nuts might devour you all I'm
saying is and correct me if I'm wrong
but all I'm trying to say is look if I
got an update right and I went from B my
prior to B prime my posterior those
things are gonna have different amounts
of entropy for instance my prior might
be completely uniform but after I've
gotten some evidence for instance the
person hit the break in some way
now I actually know that that I have
much more probability mass on the person
actually paying attention for instance
and so my belief distribution is gonna
have lower entropy and overall what the
robot is trying to do is figure out
actions that it can take so that in
expectations it reduces the entropy as
much as it can right so the robot is
trying to estimate this it holds a
belief over that right it so far what we
were doing is we were just saying okay
I'm gonna drive the way I would normally
Drive right and the person's gonna act
alongside me and I'm gonna use their
actions to update my my probability
distribution over their driving style
their internal utility right
so and so that worked fine except you
know this thing happened that we saw
here which is which is that people you
get the same observations regardless of
what theta is right you can have a theta
that stands for a very aggressive person
that theta it stands for a very
defensive person they do the same thing
and so you don't actually get to
collapse your belief at all and so here
the idea was very simple and it's um you
know something that you see an active
learning a lot but it's - ok since I get
to actually act I can be a little bit
smarter about the way I choose my action
so that I a learning that's all that's
happening here right so that I try to
instigate essentially what's gonna
happen right is that the robot is gonna
try to figure out something to do such
that if the person were say attentive
they would react very differently than
if the person were say distracted right
that's the kind of thing that will
actually give you information and
expectation whereas just driving along
them in a in a regular way it's not so
great because you know they're gonna act
in the same way so an expectation that
has low information King
to try to maximize the robot was kind of
Mike's math I try to drive I'm gonna
probably just you know try to goes zoom
left because that's gonna maximize my
immediate utility and maybe it also
gives me information yes yep yep yep so
when the robot is trying to just
maximize so this was actually the
situation from before when the robot was
actually just trying to maximize its own
selfish utility it's just that it needs
to decide on what to do based on what it
thinks that the person will do as well
so if if it's uncertain about whether
the person is paying attention or not
for instance right it won't just go
because if it just goes it has a 50%
chance that the person will just run
into them right so that's a bad bad plan
for the robot and so when it's planning
using its best estimates right as you're
using the whole probability distribution
over the person tomorrow what it decides
to do is to slow down and go behind the
person if it actually needs to merge and
that's because that's the safe thing to
do it takes a little longer time for it
to achieve its its destination but
there's not a 50% chance that will
collide with the person right so that's
what's happening there and so what we're
comparing here is really and thank you
for that question because I should
clarify we're comparing here is a model
where the robot is solely optimizing for
it's selfish utility versus what we
really do here is we trade-off right
between optimizing for my selfish
utility exploit mode right using my
current estimate and this information
gathering term and really you can see
this whole thing as a pond EP and if you
were to solve it as a pond vp everything
would be fine the robots policy would
automatically trade off in the right way
but we can't solve on DP is very well in
continuous state in action spaces and so
we kind of formulated the problem as
okay you're gonna keep on optimizing for
your selfish reward according to your
current estimate but you're we're
actually going to try to get you to get
more information and that will help
overall with the reward optimization
this is not at all a new idea it's
actually been used in navigation and
a lot in manipulation were for instance
robots try to figure out what actions to
take in order to actually localize
something right so you poke at an object
in different ways and touch it in order
to figure out where it is it's kind of
interesting here is that we're doing it
over not the physical state but the
human internal state right and the
dynamics of that are a little bit more
complicated than the dynamics we get in
manipulation so in particular this is
the optimization that we set up so which
is equivalent to this here so to kind of
even evaluate this you have to kind of
say ok if I have a you are and I want to
figure out how good that you are is in
terms of the expected information gain
well I have to think of every possible
parameter that of a possible value that
theta could get and for every possible
value that data could get I have a
probability distribution over what the
person might do and if I have this
probability distribution for everything
that the person might do I can figure
out what my B prime would be if the
person actually did this so this is even
just evaluating is computationally
difficult and so we're making here as
several approximations in order to be
able to solve this in close the real
time and so the the first thing we do is
we actually going to close our eyes and
assume that we can observe the the most
optimal behavior so instead of drawing
from the whole distribution and
considering all the possible things that
the person might do right we're just
gonna pretend like we're gonna get the
maximum likelihood observation and then
the other thing we do is we run model
predictive control so instead of solving
this for for the full time horizon that
we actually care about we're actually
solving it for a finite time horizon
executing the first action right in that
in that plan and then writing MPC again
now the final thing we do is we do a
quasi Newton method so even with model
predictive control even if you plan for
a short time horizon this is still
continuous state in action and it still
requires doing the
computation and so so we do a local
optimization creative what's interesting
here is that a local optimization relies
on being able to get a gradient of this
and getting a gradient of this relies on
being able to get the gradient of sort
of this gyuh star so to say the thing
that the person would optimally do will
respect to you are and so here we were
able to use implicit differentiation to
get an actual formula for that gradient
but it tells us as I as I perturb you
are how will the the optimal thing for
the person that a person would do get
perturbed and then finally finally we
can we go from an integral to a sum
because we don't know what else to do if
you have ideas I would really appreciate
that so basically instead of looking at
all the possible the whole space the
whole hypothesis space of possible
utility functions we sort of offlined
there's some kind of magic clustering of
user types and online we just identify
what type the person is as opposed to so
this feels a little cheap but I don't
know what else to do with that equation
so here's what happens so kind of back
to this situation what the robot is
trying to so far with the we did
something really really naive I think
what you will ideally want to do if
you're gonna go the discrete number of
possible reward functions way you know
as well first you collect data from a
lot of people you learn every word
function offline for each person and
then you try to figure out what distance
metric to use in the space of reward
functions to be able to say whether
people are similar or not and possibly
you don't use euclidean distance and
reward parameters you use the effect of
optimizing for that utility function on
the environment we haven't done that yet
but i think that you know if you're
gonna go that direction that's probably
the way to go it also feels like
if I could not discretize this I would
prefer not to I just don't know how to
approximate that integral so despite all
of this gazillion approximations that we
need to do right here's what we're
getting compared to just running passive
estimation passive inverse reinforcement
learning the robot actually miraculously
decides to nudge into the person's lane
so it's not committing to a merge it
just sort of nyjah's in a little and if
the person is distracted that's okay it
kind of goes back and so if the person
is distracted that means that the person
will keep on going that means that its
belief will get updated to have more
probability mass on the fact that that
the person is distracted because an
attentive person would have break at
least that's what its model says and so
so tough life but if the person is
actually paying attention that will go
ahead and complete the merge because it
will get this disbelief update they say
okay the person is actually paying
attention and now we can do what am i
suggested which is okay now it's
actually safe to march in front of the
person so that's nice even nicer so
actually what happens at these four-way
stops so kind of going back to the
example of cars getting stuck so what
the car decides to do is at an
intersection is it decides to inch
forward into the intersection and that's
a sort of information gathering
mechanism and it decides to inch forward
because they're kind of going back to
your points this is what people do right
they very nicely cluster you're gonna
see one one behavior from distracted
users and a very different behavior from
attentive users and that will give you
despite the fact that the observation
model is soft right is a probability
distribution you're going to get enough
information to actually be fairly
confident in the type of driver that
you're dealing with and so it's this
really this gap that's magical and it
I'm exciting how much time do I have
Andrea
okay there we work
okay so and that here what you see
plotted is the robots belief in sort of
the kind of passive case and in the case
where it gets to act to gather
information interesting we also looked
at what the robot did right so the
robots trajectories are very different
when it's dealing with distracted users
versus attentive users and this was
really cool to see so the robot decides
to inch forward and if the person is
actually paying attention that the
person behaves in one way they stop and
then the robot just continues through
the intersection that's sort of the
upper part of the curve the other part
of the curve that you see is if the
person is distracted and they're keeping
on going they're not reacting to the
robot inching forward then the robot
nicely backs up and lets them go through
and the boss that you saw were actually
generated from user studies now
admittedly in a very janky simulator not
in like a real world driving scenario
but these were real people kind of off
the street that that were interacting
with these kind of planners and it's
really exciting to me because it kind of
brings us back to this where in order to
interact properly with people you know
you can't really treat them as obstacles
and you can't really just assume a
universal model of how their drive to
make your predictions you actually have
to interact with them to figure out more
and it's really nice that this
interaction this interaction model even
though it's not too different from
inverse reinforcement learning it just
enables the robot to act and gather
information actually results in these
behaviors that we look at and they look
at like actual coordination behaviors
that we'd want to see and we don't have
to hand code them anymore or I don't
want no engineer has to sit down and say
okay inch forward at an intersection by
about this much and not this kind of
intersection but this other one and so
on just the planner figures that out got
a question
that's a very good question in our
simulations we don't really put in
constraints about the right-of-way and
so on and so this is a particularly
stops in in most not most but a lot of
the a lot of cities or states in the US
where there's no the person on the right
has right-of-way if you arrive at about
the same time you have to play the kind
of coordination game of do I go do you
go so this is the kind of situation
where we're trying to test no I mean it
will just do whatever is it and it
depends a lot on the the trade-off that
you set right before between information
information gathering and just
exploiting your your function but so you
have to be a little bit about value of
information here and said that that's
rate up accordingly but you know ideally
it will just let the person go through
if they arrive significantly earlier
because that's the optimal thing to do
regardless of what their regardless of
what driving style they have I don't
know this is explicitly what we do to
interact with people right so when we
interact with robots we probably don't
want to follow this this type of
interaction model right we probably want
to really think of it as fully a game
and we want to model what the other
robot is doing guard they arriving at a
Nash equilibrium or or not know that
this is not the cooperative case this is
very much you have different utilities
and you have to reason about it in a
different way what we found is that this
approximation of people essentially not
necessarily going all the way to a Nash
equilibria but computing a best response
to whatever the robot is doing it's
something that works fairly well in kind
of day to day interactions and there's
some evidence out there that people
don't actually solve fully solve games
when they're just out and about but
sometimes they do right okay so so this
was all I need to
I need to answer I'll skip some things I
was gonna quickly mention that when it
comes to when it comes to this other
side of learning how the passenger wants
the car to drive then you're all of the
sudden in a more and the more regular
active learning setting where you're
don't necessarily take physical actions
but you can make queries and what's
interesting about this space is that our
queries so we're looking at this type of
queries where you can ask the person to
experience two different trajectories
and say which one they would prefer and
that gives you information about their
preferences but what's interesting here
is that you don't rely on a discrete set
of queries that you're looking for to
figure out what to ask but you can
actually generate them using the same
kind of techniques from directly from
the continuous space
so that's on on acting to improve
estimation like a soul just take two
minutes if that's okay
Andreea two to talk about sort of the
flip side and just mentioned that when
so far we've talked about driving where
you typically the human and the robot
have different utilities when you make
this an actual cooperation what ends up
happening we're going to skip through
some things is that the person is gonna
for instance try to come up with the
best thing for for this is the
algorithmic teaching perspective the
person is gonna try to figure out how
the robot is learning and figure out
what demonstration they should provide
that's not necessarily the expert
demonstration but it actually helps the
robot that is running university
enforcement learning perform well and so
it's it pretty easy to show that an
expert demonstration is different from
sort of the best response to the best
response that the robot would be
computing so this is kind of inverse
reinforcement learning and now if you're
wondering what should I show the robot
if I want to teach it that's going to be
different and here's we only have toy
examples in this domain but the toy
example goes something like this imagine
this is the true reward function so
there's these peaks and the robot knows
about these peaks what the robot doesn't
know is their relative their relative
value right so which ones are good which
ones are bad and imagine this is this
your starting state and if you get an
expert demonstration what the expert
will do well the expert will do is they
will go straight to the the closest peak
the closest good peak ride wide I should
say was good so there were two white
Peaks and one and one black peak and the
robot would just go the person would
just go to the closest white peak and
you don't actually I think I'm gonna
give up on this computer and just shared
this with you myself so so the geoid
Peaks one black peak the the an expert
demonstrator would just go to the
closest wife he can hang out there the
kind of best response to an inverse
reinforcement learner would actually
visit both because that actually gives
the the robot evidence that this other
peak that wasn't visited in the expert
demonstration is also a good peak and so
that's a very very simple little toy
example right but it suggests that you
can start creating teaching
demonstrations and then the other thing
I was going to share with you is that
this actually makes a statement about
what kind of inverse me for Forsman
learners are more easy to teach in other
words what this hinges on is this
observation model that robot assumes
that the person is using to produce the
trajectories and so what we find is that
there's a little bit of a sweet spot
where if you assume that the person is
perfectly optimal there's very little
the person can do because deviating from
that basically negates everything it's
as probability zero to any reward
function that wouldn't have produced
that and then on the other extreme if
the robot assumes that the person is
very noisy right then that's also bad
you don't get a lot of information so
there's some sweet spot in the middle
that kind of the the robot has enough
flexibility in the observation model
that that enables the person to take
kind of interesting teaching actions
that it best illustrate what's what's
happening so kind of this shows that we
have to be even if we're running inverse
reinforcement learning on the robot side
we have to be a little bit careful about
what we're assuming in the observation
model underlying that
so that's basically it we're also doing
some interesting things on trying to not
assume that the person knows how the
robot learns but trying to give the
person a good mental model of the
learner and what the current robot
belief over theta is so I'm excited
about that and that falls squarely under
algorithmic teaching and just kind of to
pop back I'm excited about the fact that
you know you no longer have a person
giving you a demonstration still one
person one robot but you don't have a
person that is an uninterested expert
giving you a demonstration and then a
robot that passively observed what's
going on but you're trying to actually
have an interactive process and even
though there's many approximations
involved and so on I think we're seeing
some evidence that looking at the
problem this way can actually
significantly speed up learning
[Applause]
balance gathering information and yeah
so how do you islands got any
information with safety so the safety
part is in the robots robots reward
right and the robot is trading off
between gathering information and and
exploiting it's it's it's kind of
selfish reward function and there are
some techniques that look at adapting
this trade-off over time
right so for in and what I've showed so
far you just we just set it to something
and that's clearly the wrong thing to do
right you want to be able to reason
about the value of that information that
you would gain as it would it really
change the plan that you would come up
with so those are things to desert think
about there's a community and we know
within approximating palm vp's that has
thought about that sort of the two
things that we've managed to look at I
think that's a great question it's it's
I don't if we could solve the game
tractable II I don't think that that's
the right thing to do anyway because I
don't think that that's what they would
model the person as solving the game
perfectly as well and and that doesn't
really happen right and so I think it's
yeah it's a question of the the robot
learner being different the robot
learner relaxing the assumption that I
think the game already is making a lot
of assumptions about the person actually
having perfect not the only don't let me
say this way the only missing knowledge
is on the robot side and the person has
perfect information and that's not truly
the case so there's kind of parts of the
state there that we're missing the
person has its own beliefs over things
and I think that would be a really big
bang for the buck I don't sense that
kind of iterating on best responses
further and further would actually buy
us that much
great thank you
[Applause]